welcome to this video playing alexa from
Israel he's one of the real old-timers
of ICC is he's playing there for like I
don't know okay if I'm saying old-timers
it's like like me like 15 years or
something just quickly checking he's got
some old stats here from 2000 best blitz
ratings from two thousand thirteen years
ago okay so we have a nympho the
Rubenstein variation with Bishop d3 and
92 so some quite an interesting way for
black sorry for white to play back here
it's an isolated queen palm position
with them the slightly unusual twist of
night only two so I think taking a d5
this was the recipe that i always
recommend it in my book I mean in the
head and the right now being in the
works book it's not finished yet but
this is something I'm working on but the
book is sound about um let's say ninety
percent about ninety percent finished
some the release date which is scheduled
for november december something like
that is probably still on realistic but
okay i'm not quite sure about them what
final thinks they'll need to be done
because it's my first book so I don't
really know so much about the final
final steps and processing like printing
and so on I want all the stakes okay but
back to the game here quite an
interesting position I've taken on xiii
played in five and now i really like to
play a five-foot it's an aggressive move
but i want to make sure that the night
is not coming to e4 I'd have a good
center here it's quite nice the question
is c4 I would have liked to prevent you
form but maybe I never had the chance to
do so okay on c4 I want to play Bishop
basics at least yeah I'm threatening on
c3
hmm
okay I wonder about the three this is a
possibility
hmm
there's some way to improve my position
if you if I would be able to prevent see
334 I would be absolutely great but be
five it's not a play will move I think
now not not really okay so let's go here
this is also not bad intending to to do
this here gaining a tempo and then night
be 72 d 6 or to see 5
I don't know this should be a form
should I have prevented that yeah I want
I want to catch up a bit on the clock so
playing a bit with them so to see 5 or
26 both looking noise survivor sir the
more aggressive way to go Wow
hmm ok let's open up
yeah I control the e-file this is why f4
surprised me
his pawn is really not dangerous so
nicely located
and so my ideas just try to invade on e3
so rookie 5 rupee aid rookie three
coming
all rookie do hmm well f-for yeah this
is actually a good f4 just pushing bones
this one okay Queen h5
yeah I can prepare this he cannot really
do so much
Queen to h5 hmm
yeah but it's okay i can play Queen h6
okay it doesn't replace what retreating
seems very weird this looks are just
like a big game for black for nothing
yeah i forgot about this more
I simply forgot that you can play that
before that white is just completely
outplayed for from absolutely nothing
time warning I turn nonsense really
check check
check
check-check
all right glad ya reason is it yet how
can I spoil this I mean this is like
yeah complete completely out over now
the white is just busted in this
position I can do whatever I want except
probably what I played let's let's check
how to how to do this yeah I'm always
I'm really pissed at myself too well why
not win this I mean I play like 30 moves
completely out playing the sky it is
just we cannot even move is it but you
need to be precise which I feel today I
had I just overlooked age form yeah well
okay the if you just give it to a
competent it's just 95 s minus 3 but
this is not a very human move okay if
you look at this widest bastard I cannot
prevent in this year just I'm just
attacking for for nothing but ok you
don't really want to give this excellent
be sure a night against the stupid
bishop but I've overlooked edge from
Quincy for still wins yeah this yeah
this is good for right now yeah I'd here
I'm I'm completely losing the threat of
course yeah I overlooked edge for simply
but this is the easiest and now we
cannot prevent the g porn from advancing
why this is he kept up news it's full of
weaknesses and the guy played two played
a very strange game here f4 as just a
disaster I mean just the disaster giving
up basically the game I'm having the
e-file as the dark squared weaknesses
and the excellent night on c5
and after that its own it's very nice
actually until I until I fell apart
missing the H formal the an-94 yarn I de
force easiest i can even play a rock g3
i mean probably this is yeah he can
still play age for ya shouldn't allow
that really each room i forgot about the
smooth alright an interesting game
nevertheless thanks for watching